hey guys real quick so you don't think I  fell off the face of the planet i'm  getting married up here in Sonoma  California this week so I'm doing a full  online shutdown which I announced on  Twitter but then I realized some of you  youtubers might not be on the twitter  anyway I am disconnecting I'm recharging  focusing on the personal life for a  little bit I will be back beginning of  September the all-new Ruben report  debuts on or a TV on September ninth  trust me you guys are going to dig the  first guess we have a ton of awesome  stuff in store for you and I'm going to  come back refreshed and recharged and  focus like never before we're onto  something I can feel it I think you guys  can feel it and I'm really psyched but  in the meantime I'm just going to enjoy  this for a little bit and be back soon  thanks